[Music]
good evening the statewide pause is now
in full effect
thanks for joining us here at six i'm
denise feldick and i'm david charns
brian is on assignment tonight
now these new restrictions include
limiting capacity at various businesses
to 25 percent
a news now reporter kristen drummond
visits two restaurants to see how
they're adjusting on this first day
less people and only four chairs at a
table the temporary layout for parkway
tavern on 215
and flamingo some of the bigger tables
that are up in the dining area were six
seats tables
they're all down to four seats a new
requirement served up during the
statewide pause
it's impacting a lot of our businesses
differently jonathan fine owns the
24-hour bar and restaurant as well as a
few others in the valley
on the strip we have rock house pbr
at planet hollywood american and the
link
and the mint which is on sahara he
anticipated the restrictions but
does not expect to lay off employees
despite the potential loss in business
for three weeks we're going to bite the
bullet and we're going to
keep the staff as is
wolfgang puck players locker also plans
to keep staff
we're just managing the schedule so that
everybody gets some work time
the restaurant welcomed guests for lunch
for the first time tuesday with the 25
percent capacity regulation
that means around 80 people can now eat
here
do i like it no it's going to hurt
business it'll hurt volume
but if we don't do it right we're going
to have too many people
get sick to comply with the new
restrictions staff removed tables from
the main dining area
and also placed a cookbook and wine
bottle on tables not in use
that way it'll look more complete than
an empty tabled restaurant
necessary adjustments to comply and keep
staff and customers safe
kristin drummond 8 news now now the
state restrictions also require
reservations so for instance in parkway
tavern
they will ask customers who walk in
typically to reserve a spot on the app
open table
before they can be seated if there's
space